oh my god we had the best time ever oh
my god i mean i it's like i was reading
some of the questions and like going
through it with our amazing producer and
i was like oh my god and then this and
then there was this and then there was
that and like then i came across the
story that you remembered okay so
one of them
we were well one of them was uh we were
on a private jet which is always so
memorable that was i'd never been on a
private jet before and i was i didn't
know how it worked like who's flying it
and then we got on we were all i just
was trying to like behave because i felt
like i didn't belong there and then by
the end we were like trying to like
throw cheetos into each other's mouths
and like yes we got really comfortable
really quick we got really comfy yeah
because i was like 19 and like washed up
and trying to come back like i was not
private jetting it anywhere
um i was you were so
i don't know you were so adorable and
sweet and so glamorous in this way and
we'd i remember whoopi and i would come
get you in the golf cart and be like
hey and you'd be like what'd you do this
weekend i'd be like i got a new hat and
i'd be like what'd you do and you went i
got a new husband and i was like hey
what what do you
it's true really i remember that so well
and whoopi of course was like
what yeah like you did what over the
weekend i was like i got married
you know and sometimes
it's a weekend you have to have an
activity
it was in a bar it was an accident
everything happened in bars
we've all been in bars we called like a
dial-a-preacher did they have those yeah
back then um so okay you are in a play
right now called how i learn to drive
yeah um shockingly cool full circle fact
you are doing it with the incredible
actor david morris there's history there
yeah we did the play 25
i can't add suddenly 25 years ago yeah
i mean you did this play yeah because i
was 30. so i'm 57 so and you look so hot
you walked out i was like oh my god oh
my god what
what fountain
what
where'd you sell your soul what fountain
are you drinking out i think i decided a
while ago that um it's really tempting
to kind of like mess with yourself but i
decided i wanted i'd rather look like
a young old lady than an old young lady
you know i don't know i've never heard
it put that way no i i don't know that i
have either but um and i love that yeah
there's something to like also being
able to say like
i'm 57 years old and i've lived every
single one of those years and i'm not
trying to like look 52 or 49 or you know
what i am how healthy that is too
i've
it's so healthy
it really is i can't think of a better
film that i would love to pick your
brain about that i think is such an
extraordinary celebration of women and
such a timeless classic is fried green
tomatoes because that is both
perspective
that is the younger and the older
and boy in that film does it just i've
got chills talking about it that is a
film that really celebrates wisdom
aging life maturity i mean i think
growing up is not overrated i like it i
love it there's something when i when i
i was really worried when i turned 50
and then i turned 50 and i couldn't stop
saying it i was like i'm 50. i'm 50. i'm
50.
um did you have a good time making that
movie because boy do we have the best
time watching it yeah i i felt really
lucky to be a part of it i hadn't made
many movies and i just felt i couldn't
believe that they gave me the part and
working with those other actresses kathy
bates and jessica tandy and mary stewart
it was just it felt like oh here you go
like there here's this enormous gift and
it just i just felt really
lucky and we worked you know mary
stewart works really hard and we worked
really hard and there were there was a
strange incident that where i had to
jump into a pool
uh
lake actually
and they told me ahead of time there are
no
um water moccasins they'd scanned the
area but they had not scanned for
leeches
wait did you get leeches
one i got leech
yeah where is the part of your body
um let's just say
somewhere in this region
yeah not good so and i was wearing a
slur
[Music]
yeah down below i was wearing a slip and
i had to jump into the uh
to this little pond which had no snakes
but leeches i'd rather a leech than a
snake i think
yeah i'm okay with snakes but
not water moccasins but then they said
oh can we get somebody i guess there was
like a whole because it was the south
and they were just kind of used to it
they a grip came over with a big flame
yep yeah and just burned it
right off and then i did another take
and i was like back on the horse back in
the water
back in the water i mean what are the
chances i get one again very small
[Music]
you